hay cuatro estaciones cada año rafael se
corta el cabello dos veces cada estación
una en la barbería arlo y otra en la
peluquería tijeras impresionantes quiero
opciones representan el número de cortes
de cabello que se hará rafael este año
elige todas las opciones correctas
bueno aquí están las opciones que nos
dan y aquí abajo nos dan una tablita en
donde están los cortes que se hace
rafael cada estación
aquí en primavera este es el corte que
se hace en arlo y este es el corte que
se hacen tijeras impresionantes aquí en
verano
este es el corte que se hacen arlo y
después el corte que se hacen tijeras
impresionantes lo mismo para otoño corte
en haz lo corta en tijeras
impresionantes y en
su corte en arlo su corte en tijeras
impresionantes son los dos cortes que se
hacen de cabello este rafael en cada
estación veremos por ejemplo en
primavera se hace un corte en arlo y un
corte en tijeras impresionantes entonces
para primavera se corta dos veces el
cabello y después llega verano y en
verano se hace estos dos cortes así que
en verano se hace otros dos
llega el otoño se hace su corte en arlo
su corte en tijeras impresionantes son
dos así que para otoño hay otros dos
cortes finalmente en invierno su corte
en arlo su corte en tijeras
impresionantes son dos cortes en
invierno así que con todos estos ya
tenemos los cortes que se hace en un año
completo dos de primavera dos de verano
dos de otoño y dos de invierno
si hacemos la suma vemos que dos más dos
son cuatro estos otros dos más dos
también son 4 y 44
van a ser 88 cortes de cabello va a ser
rafael en todo un año ahora veamos las
opciones que nos dan nos dicen elige
todas las opciones correctas
la primera opción 2 + 2 pues no aquí
vemos las opciones que encontramos era
dos más dos más dos más dos pero no hay
ninguna que sólo sea dos más dos sería
sólo la mitad del año así que esta
opción no es correcta la siguiente 4444
tampoco tenemos dos más dos más dos más
dos o cuatro cuatro y no tenemos está
esta tampoco es correcta tenemos 44
estas y 44 que es igual a 2 más 2
y otros dos más dos está si aplica esta
si es de las opciones correctas
esta otra 22 2 más 2 también aquí está
sumamos 2 4 veces 1 2 3 4 y aquí sumamos
también 2 4 veces
1 2 3 4 aquí está esta opción que es
correcta está también y la otra dos más
cuatro pues no está no la tenemos porque
nuestro resultado al final de todo el
año es 8 y 2 más 4 no nos da 8 y no
tenemos combinaciones así aquí que
coinciden con esta esta no es una opción
válida son estas dos las opciones que
nos representan los cortes de cabello
que se hace rafael en un año